[Applause]
it's fair to say demonstrators at the
people's vote march don't like brexit
much they turned out in their hundreds
of thousands in London hoping MPs voting
on Boris Johnson's brexit deal in
Parliament's would hear them the current
deal is appalling so No Deal is bad
yes this deal is bad yes the only thing
you like is remain and if the people in
that votes said we still want to leave
you'd be happy with that would you much
happier but of course most hope a second
referendum would overturn rexes
particularly if the lever vote could be
split between Boris Johnson's Deal and
No Deal
why are you here well I'm French so we
have food happy you know I've lived here
thirty years I've worked I've raised my
children I've paid my taxes I do
voluntary work and now I'm treated like
a second-class citizen for a deal that's
gonna wreck the economy and the future
of my children where else would I be
but mp's didn't reject Boris Johnson's
deal and they haven't given the country
a second referendum what they have done
is passed an amendment which requires
Boris Johnson to request a brexit
deadline extension of three months eyes
to the right
322 the nose to the left 306 so the eyes
have it the eyes have it unlocked
anteye brexit demonstrators are taking
this as a battle victory though even if
they fear they are losing the war
well the many thousands of people who
have marched and landed on Saturday know
that what Parliament has just done does
not stop wrecks it but what it does
crucially is get them more time and more
time means a better chance still a slim
one though that they can achieve their
aim a second referendum
Rory challon's al-jazeera London